the lefty will come at you with a heater
that averages 94. slider and a curveball
he'll sink that fastball as well has to
change up leadoff walk for the rockies
here in the nightcap brendan rogers the
hitter and this ball is hit pretty well
to right center field does it have a
chance to fly you bet opposite field
two-run home run brendan rodgers that's
the start the rockies were looking for a
walk and a bomb
and for brennan rogers his tenth of the
year
went upstairs and got him to swing and
miss
for the rockies airmont marcus
on the mound looking for his 12th
victory swung out of miss on a good
slider and there is strikeout number one
on the evening for herman will not be
his last a pretty confident saying
and that one served into left that's a
base hit half the other way
he stays high
and on the ground to third potter's got
it
to rogers and that ends the first inning
so the rockies will carry a two-nothing
lead to inning number two at wrigley
justin steele facing garrett hampson
outside that's a really good at bat for
hampson something that you know he wants
to do as he gets more at bats at the big
league level he's gonna hope to walk
more
and he did and he did
well done by justin steele a strikeout
there's one away he had him as you said
with that o2 count
let him get away i mean that's just
quality right there that's just climbing
the ladder
runner takes off pitch is cut on and
missed
[Music]
wow
great job sherrino's
getting one of the fastest guys in
baseball and garrett hampson that is a
great throw
right there got him looking good job by
justin steele gets some help from his
catcher
a good way in the second is
[Music]
just well placed softly hit it'll be an
infield single for david body
[Applause]
harris will hold him up jason's into
second
and it comes with runners at second and
third and nobody out hayward a double
robinson made that perfect throw in the
top of the inning to cut down garrett
hampson trying to steal
taps
[Music]
scores and it is 2-1 so a run in it's
2-1 and they're at the corners alcantara
haywards the runner at third sherino's
the runner at first 3-2 there goes the
runaway
[Applause]
hayward will come in it's an rbi single
for alcantara and it's 2-2
one more time went back to that elevated
fastball and
alecandra up on his toes with a good
level swing to line that ball to center
field
to our score one and all the count
base hit left field the cubs have the
lead
ortega the other way rbi single
and it's 3-2 as alcantara comes in
rodella strikeout his first time all for
one
spindle lines that base it to left field
hanging breaking ball coming in to score
justin steele stopping at second rafael
ortega frank schwendell with a solid run
scoring hit and the cubs lead four to
two ortega's at third half at first
runner goes
lookie here wow look at that
steals the base runs scores it's 5-2
[Applause]
man you're not kidding it was just like
somebody hit the pause button
and ortega said yep i'm gonna come in to
score that two strikes on wisdom
normally you're not gonna be too daring
on the base slugger up there but with
two strikes that changes the thinking a
little bit
these kind of innings did he go he did
so that will finally get the rockies to
the dugout
but an enormous inning for the cubs they
score five times in a variety of ways
[Music]
one two and that curveball hard curve
ball will lock up robbie torino so much
needed one two three inning from hermann
diaz will lead it off when we come back
rocky's trail by three
1-0 pitch is hit towards left and
that'll be a base hit oh elias diaz
starts the fourth with the single
rocky's got two straight hits to begin
the third but could not take advantage
and that ball's left up and promptly
swatted to left good job by garrett
hampson behind in the count taking that
curveball again the first two men reach
here in the fourth as was the case in
the third and so that loads the bases
for conor joe
gear up for that fastball coming and
this ball is drilled to deep center
field did joe get all of it
you bet grand slam cutter joe
how big was that from a 5-2 deficit to a
6-5 lead at the legend gross
hampson singled and scored on the connor
joe homer
this ball hit hard through the middle of
the diamond to base hit for hampson two
base hits and a walk for garrett thumb
base all three times two there
that just cut out and missed through no
safe strikeout but the stolen base and
now a man in scoring position so this is
rio ruiz 1-1 this ball is well hit to
left field and it is gonna go into the
ivy hampson comes home it'll be a double
for ruiz left on left off the bench he
gives the rockies a two run lead
that was large rogers a two-run home run
in the first his tenth of the year he
popped out in the third and struck out
swinging in the fourth
2-0 and this is up the middle base hit
around third comes ruiz he'll score
easily
and going first to third is connor joe
brennan rogers a three rbi
ball game and the rockies extend their
lead to eight to five bottom of the
seventh daniel bardon to try and save it
20 saves and 27 opportunities for the
rockies closer now the 1-1 from bard
in the air out towards center
it's
hampshire
in half gets it out of here and it's
eight eight well dom started in game one
had a base hitting a strikeout
and this ball back up the middle of base
hit that is huge hansen will score
easily
dom nunez coming through off the bench
and the pinch hitters continue to be on
a great run for the rockies remember it
was matt duffy who started the rally in
the seventh with a lead-off single off
of bard
on the ground
story picks it up
[Applause]
he is a third with one out
this ball is lifted to deep left field
it'll get a run in maybe more god
it kept going and ryan mcmahon
hits a two-run go-ahead home run
[Music]
and this ball lined down the left field
line
rogers is going to drive in
hilliard
and freeland's going to come around it's
a two-run double and the rockies now
have a four-run lead
a five-rbi evening for brendan rodgers a
new career high now the shortstop sergio
alcantra
[Music]
that's strike three and that
ends game two the rockies finally
prevail